and sort of finish up here obviously
you've got kind of two parts of your
brain right now let's think of right
you've got the the medical side and the
training that you've done there and
obviously the hours and hours that you
spent kind of looking at this and
starting to identify some of the
potential solutions but then you also
are an investor in your managing capital
and things like that where's the
crossover in terms of how do you see
coronavirus and the economic impact kind
of continuing over across different
markets in the coming weeks and months
yeah so it's constantly changing I think
you have to kind of look out for three
different potential paths coming up over
the next few months or years so there's
the first path where we do find a
medication a treatment or a prophylactic
they can flatten the curve reduce the
symptoms reduce the fatality rate or
reduce them where people that get
infected and that could bias time until
it may be a vaccine is developed or even
until we have herd immunity and this
thing in coronavirus just becomes almost
like the floor of a seasonal flu and not
really a big deal the second path is the
virus mutates a little bit so almost
like h1n1 where it was kind of thought
of as a big deal tality right and then
it kind of mutated in a way where a lot
of people got it so in fact a lot of
people but the mortality was actually
quite low so that's why I didn't even
hit the radar all that much and most
really know how many people are actually
affected by it and then the third path
would be if iris does not mutate it it
we do not have a medication your vaccine
work then that's scarier obviously and
what I think you could be looking at is
maybe and this is based off China and
South Korea how the cases have
stabilized there's a number of new cases
is dramatically dropping that is this
have to do with the woman weather coming
in and are we gonna see a second wave
come the fall and that's what a lot of
people compare this to the Spanish flu
of 1918 where it had its first wave that
kind of ended around June July and it
wasn't until about October November the
second wave came in and that's one that
really wiped out a lot of people and so
that's something is you're gonna be
looking out for is
if this does settle down that's great
that's fantastic but keeping a close eye
for infections in areas come the fall on
a short-term basis for Americans look at
Italy we're running about 10 days by in
Italy so what Italy is going through now
will be America most likely in ten days
and this just seems so obvious to me
over the past couple weeks and so that's
what is interesting a couple weeks ago
almost no one was really talking whereas
almost like a joke
and you awkward if you weren't shake
someone's hand or something now it's not
if you actually just look at those
stories coming out of Italy about the
people living there what that life is
like prepare for that because that could
easily be America in ten days and I
think it's already getting very close to
that and so looking for stabilization of
corners again look at Italy when those
cases stop going up and stabilized I
think that's good news and I think that
there's hope for the stabilizing at
least over the summer and then what to
revisit it in the fall and then I think
the market so Bitcoin and Bitcoin
cryptocurrency I think it all kind of
goes that when in something this massive
it seems like it kind of is trading
along with it when the economy is going
down it's it's brisk on asset and it
goes down as well yeah one of the things
that I've heard and I don't know if it's
true or not is that once you get
coronavirus you basically can't get
reinfected right so the population
itself some portion could get infected
it goes away and comes back and could
reinfect other people but is it true
that the individual itself once you have
it you can't get it again or is it just
too early to know whether that's
accurate or not so that's typically how
viruses work once you get a viral
infection you can't get that really
exact same viral infection there can be
different strains of it though that's
why you can get the flu multiple years
it's not like you get the flu once and
you're no you never get the flu again
another strain think about the next year
or you might give acted with a different
strain even that year they are finding
though that
are my patients that test negative after
they've been treated later than test
positive again for the virus and so
that's concerning in some ways than the
thought that are they not treating
patients long enough is this some type
of reinfection and so that that's that
data is being studied now but I'm
inclined to think that's how you get
here in a herd immunity is eventually as
you if you get infected you won't get it
again so that's kind of a hope but it's
not definitive at this point got it and
those different strains I think the
other thing I've heard is basically when
the warm weather comes it may kind of
migrate south to South America Latin
America etc but there could be mutations
and then when the cold weather returns
later this year North America for
example that's where really there could
be some problems because now you're not
just talking about the corona virus but
it could be multiple strains of this or
kind of mutations that even if you
already had it you're still susceptible
to the new stuff yeah exactly I think
that one thing that people argue that
for going away during the summer is
increased temperature will dry out the
the virus in some ways and then also the
increased humidity so it's gonna give
this heat tennis sun drying up like then
you also have a humidity in the air
which will stop the spread of the virus
because if there's enough air water
particles in the area will stop the the
viral particles from kind of you know
projecting when you talk or sneeze or
cough got it that's super interesting
okay and then what do you think is kind
of the if you had a guess right now what
does this look like over the next kind
of six to eight weeks do we flatten a
curve you know two weeks from now and
and kind of start moving back towards
you know everyday life do we stay in
kind of this self quarantined you know
even sometimes a shelter in place for
four weeks months like how do you think
this plays out given the information you
have today you're gonna be quarantined
for at least weeks I would say at least
a month
a couple months three months it kind of
depends on this thesis on this thing
slowing down for the summer but I think
we're in for a rocky few weeks coming up
and it looked like Italy was stabilized
a little bit but then they recorded a
record number of new cases yesterday and
another record number it looks like
today so it's we haven't had any yeah
there's been no evidence this is slowing
down really for Italy or Europe and so
that that's not good news for us right
now either got it and then what do you
take in terms of China I think today
we're recording on a on Thursday March
19th
it was either yesterday or today they
reported no new cases so you know
quote-unquote zero new cases can we
trust the data you know how do you kind
of fit that data point into this whole
thing so I'm an in contact with people
that have come back in China and they
feel convinced that China has it under
control and if that data is real that's
always been the question that was from
the very beginning you know China didn't
really want to announce that this was
the virus she had the whistleblowers
there originally persecuted and now
praised and so there is this always this
distrust of the information from China
but South Korea has kind of very
positive results I think Singapore has
been doing a good job controlling this
and so it's possible it's also possible
in the kind of social infrastructure
side of things I think in China and
South Korea you know the social
distancing is maybe a lot easier or if
the government recommends it or imposes
it it's done much more effectively
whereas in Italy in the u.s. you know I
feel like well you know screw that I I
know I'm gonna go kiss whoever's cheek I
want i'ma go to the bars and so I think
that it really takes a little bit more
to scare people and now people are
starting to get scared where maybe
they're scaling back on that a little
bit but if you read a lot of the
Italians what they're telling Americans
right now is do that no don't don't wait
until it's so bad that you you know
there's a curfew you can get if you're
outside I can check in Italy right now
if you go outside you have to
essentially have a pass or a very good
evidence but reason for being out
otherwise you get fined and the only
reason you really ought to go out is to
go pick up medication or to go to
grocery stores yeah
the other thing I just saw literally
right before we started recording and
again so I'll caveat with I haven't had
the time to look at the accuracy of it
is Israel is actually implementing
martial law
so like the actual true martial law
where the government or the military is
going to enforce people staying inside
curfews you know all of this kind of
non-essential traffic etc and so I think
that we're probably far away away from
that you know in the US for example or
other places but you know depending on
people's reactions I think that yeah
there is this overarching feeling of
like we've got to flatten that curve and
kind of fight back against us I would
say there's a nonzero chance some
version of martial law comes to the US
as well in the next two or three weeks I
mean if this thing continues to spread
and people aren't voluntarily isolating
themselves then it's definitely possible
I wouldn't it wouldn't surprise me the
next two or three weeks which sounds
crazy yeah for American it's especially
cuz lot of Americans have guns once a
little bit of a different well III was
explaining some of the other day if you
would have said four or five weeks ago
you know hey the stock marks then go
down 30% there's the possibility of
martial law you know all these different
things people to look at you like you're
nuts and in a very short period of time
you know here we are yeah exactly and I
think that people could be in for a bit
more surprises the next couple weeks
yeah well let's let's all hope not and
hopefully we go to the master over there
but they're going to get back to normal
absolutely yeah but James listen I
really appreciate you coming on on such
short notice and helping us understand
this where can people find you online
and kind of find more about what what
you're tracking I'm at paying attention
to James Spadaro MD is my Twitter
account looks like Joe just put it on
the screen there that's the best way to
polish it
I know it's quick that's the way I talk
about corner - updates a lot of times
its effect and the Bitcoin
cryptocurrency markets and that's what I
talk about on my crypto insights as well